Need to make sure that your hair is the way that I like it.
People always ask,
what are some of the red flags that I missed or that I overlooked?
And this one really strikes such a nerve because one of our first huge,
big blow up arguments was over my hair.
We were gonna go to a party
and bump into some of his old high school friends
from back in the day.
Some people he wanted to impress.
Always mooching off at the woman's cloud.
But anyway,
and he was like, hey,
I really like it when you blow dry your hair straight.
It looks so fabulous when you blow dry it straight and get it all wavy
and, you know, beautiful.
And so I took my curly ass hair
and tried everything I could do to get it straight.
But it was a hot summer night and it was a little humid.
It wasn't working.
I know what he was wanting me to go for, and it wasn't coming out.
So I just threw it back in a bun and I was like, hey,
you know, like,
this is kind of the best I can do because of the night.
It's hot, we're gonna be outside.
Like, this is also just, like, more practical.
Like, if I wear my hair blow dried and like, with the flips,
you know, it's gonna look like shit halfway through the night.
So the effect that we're going for, anyway,
Is not gonna be.
It's gonna look good right now,
and by the time we get there,
it's gonna look like shit.
I mean, a fucking screaming match over what a disappointment I was. And,
oh, my god. Okay,
I guess that's good enough.
I mean, I hope my friends are still, like,
all kinds of guilt and shame and making me feel so ugly and, like,
I'm lucky that I even get to be there. And.
And then we compromised on some other hairstyle,
and I remember just being, like,
really self conscious all night, and him just kind of, like,
giving me looks all night.
And I was like,
you know, maybe he was just really nervous to meet his old friends.
He was, you know,
I mean, like,
it was. I get it.
It's a lot of pressure,
you know? Like,
he just. You know.
I mean, I do want him to be, like,
proud and excited about his girlfriend.
Like, I totally just ignored my whole gut feeling on that one.
Big regret. Big,
big, big regret.